- Les gens respirent de l'air
dans lequel il y a du glyphosate
et des pesticides de synthèse.
- Ils sont une quarantaine
de maires en France qui,
comme Daniel Cueff, ont décidé
d'interdir totalement
le glyphosate sur leur
territoire. Sa petite commune,
située en Bretagne, compte
600 habitants et 700 vaches.
(applaudissements)
Ses concitoyens lui demandaient
d'agir depuis longtemps.
- 35 habitants ont fait
des prélèvements d'urine.
Beaucoup d'entre eux mangent
100 % bio. Leurs enfants mangent
bio à la cantine municipale
et ils ont découvert des taux
de glyphosate 30 fois supérieurs
à la norme autorisée. Ils sont
tombés de leur armoire. Ils ont
dit : "Mais c'est pas possible.
On pensait avoir un peu de
glyphosate, mais à ce point,
c'est pas possible."
- Mais le maire de Langouët
et ses habitants ont été déçus.
La cour a cassé la décision.
Le temps de juger sur le fond,
à savoir si oui ou non
le glyphosate est bel et bien
dangereux pour la santé.
Car les agences de sécurité
sanitaire, en Europe comme
aux État-Unis ou au Canada,
qui sont sensées veiller sur
l'impact de l'environnement sur
notre santé, ne considèrent pas
le glyphosate comme cancérogène.
Malgré l'avis contraire
de l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé.
- Ce sont des agences qui
s'appuient essentiellement
sur les documents secrets
de l'industrie et non pas sur
les publications scientifiques
qui ont été faites au cours
des dernières années.
- La sociologue de l'UQAM,
Louise Vandelac, spécialisée en
environnement, a été outrée de
voir que Santé Canada a autorisé
le glyphosate jusqu'en 2032,
n'y voyant aucun problème
pour la santé des Canadiens.
- Quand il s'agit d'études
qui sont faites par
les scientifiques, ce sont
les études qui, dans plus
des deux tiers des cas,
ce sont des études critiques qui
mettent en évidence certains
des risques pour la santé.
Ce qui est le cas pour moins
de 1 % des études faites
par l'industrie.
- En effet, selon
les compilations récentes,
les études faites par
les scientifiques indépendants
concluent dans 70 % des cas que
le glyphosate est bel et bien
toxique. Celles financées par
Monsanto, aujourd'hui propriété
de la firme allemande Bayer,
le producteur de Roundup, disent
le contraire dans 99 % des cas.
Qui dit vrai?
La controverse s'est transportée
devant les tribunaux qui, de
plus en plus, auront à trancher.
En 2018, cet employé municipal
d'une banlieue de San Francisco,
atteint d'un des cancers les
plus souvent liés au glyphosate,
a fait l'histoire. Il a réussi
à démontrer que sa maladie était
causée par l'épandage
du Roundup, qui faisait partie
de son travail. Le tribunal a
condamné Monsanto à lui verser
près de deux 300 millions $.
Cette décision, contestée
en appel par la compagnie,
a été la première.
Quelques autres ont suivi
qui vont dans le même sens.
Et ce n'est pas fini.
À ce jour, 18 400 personnes ont
entrepris des actions en justice
contre Monsanto-Bayers,
aux États-Unis, 175 au Canada
et 55 au Québec.
Ici Alexandra Szacka, Radio-Canada, Montréal